schoolbooks about Spanish history are
being printed at our EMU graphic arts
aliado Munoz's company also produces
travel guides cookbooks and
encyclopedias his printing business in
Madrid is working to capacity but the
costs for paper and ink needed for each
new order must be funded in advance as
customers only pay months later simonas
often needs to take out a loan pero no
se como la nuestra is for a company like
ours we're talking figures of between
half a million and 1 million euros not
huge numbers I'm just wondering on this
kind of da middle the problem is that
the bank's demand very high guarantees
but others can do is to get a loan you
must provide guarantees worth three to
four times what they give you tienes que
van a dar con con tres cuatro veces la
cantidad estan dando this means his
company has great difficulties getting
loans the economic crisis hit his
business hard and that's made the bank's
wary in 2008 ammonia's had to shut down
two of his for printing businesses and
let go half of his staff today he
employs 100 people the entrepreneur
doesn't think much of the European
Central Bank's recent interest rate cut
no no see me steady saya tanto el precio
del dinero we're not much interested in
the price of money porque per game our
country yes but not with small business
owners why that's the way banks and the
state get cheap credit its of no use to
us because the cash never reaches us it
looks as if they're trying to make money
flow more freely but borrowing it is
still hard and pricey the corridor
degeneres and northern Madrid is a
region with 20,000 small businesses they
were hit hard by the economic crisis
many went bankrupt or moved away
business people from the region have
gathered at the annual meeting of the
annales entrepreneurs association almost
all find it hard to get credit but the
association's president has good news
the province of madrid plans to invest
240 million euros in the region he also
views the ECB's interest rate cut as
helpful it wasn't evil you know that I
think it's very positive and will
generate growth the drop in the interest
rate will help us find financing on the
market they did this for the benefit of
small and medium-sized businesses we'll
see how this helps small businesses grow
come or are you know further feenin
theatre I think it'll be very
interesting yogesh when we do the same
thing I colada and Aras the largest city
in the region Jose Carlo Diaz is a
well-known economist in Spain and one of
the Spanish government's harshest
critics he's been following Spanish
Prime Minister Mariano Rajoy's plans for
a new economic stimulus package and
increased support for small businesses
locust a pro poniendo nice a plan
fatigue on these plans are simply a
hodgepodge of various measures for
instance 700 million euros is to go to
financing small and medium-sized
companies mis en Espana I in Spain these
businesses have around a billion euros
in debts so creating a 700 million euro
rescue package is like giving a
critically ill patient of pain reliever
I colada I Maris is the birthplace of
Miguel de Cervantes author of Don
Quixote when fighting the economic
crisis Spain must make sure that it to
doesn't wind up tilting at windmills